you got your start as a lifeguard on a
soap opera yes that's how you got
started by playing a live great a
lifeguard an actual lifeguard yeah no
they're not many soap operas there were
a guard here and a pool yeah no no it
took there was no water anywhere they're
just for safety reasons
you played a lifeguard on a soap opera
called Sunset Beach yes and you won the
role in a contest is that right yeah it
was a crazy thing you know Aaron
Spelling did basically the American Idol
thing before American Idol did it
basically he went out to a bunch of
cities and opened it up and said anybody
who wants to try and be on this show
come on down and so you know they're
like you know 25 young and sexy and I
saw like fifty five-year-old people in
there and all different shapes and sizes
but I got a job and you know got a
contest out of a contest in a mall got a
three-year-long
you went to a mall and took your shot
and you got the gig King of Prussia Mall
in Philadelphia that is so cool yeah I
mean I was going to school to study
acting at the time right but just stop
pay the bills and hands down pay the
bills got me in the game got me out here
to LA I think we have a picture here of
you and your co-stars this is what is
this the what what's going on this is
that I'm now realizing why I wasn't cast
on that show that was the boy band I
started back a little boy baby yeah
everything about that is wrong yeah
you